-Today's Friday.
-Really?
-Yeah, that's usually when I
catch up on some personal stuff.
-Really?
-Oh, yeah, I get my --
-What else do you do?
-Well, I check my inbox,
return e-mails, of course
I send out thank you notes.
It's Friday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Would you guys...?
Would you guys mind
if I wrote out
some thank you notes tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Right now?
-Now.
-Now?
-Yeah, in the middle
of the show.
-Wow.
-James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
I would love some.
[ Piano music playing gently ]
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
Why is it...?
-Wow. That's the
Miami Sound "Asleep" Machine.
-Yeah. Why is he...?
[ Laughs ]
Why is he so excited?
-I don't know.
He loves the conga.
-Yeah. [ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Thank you, Ron DeSantis,
for being on a mission
to destroy two Donalds --
Trump and Duck.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-[ Imitates Donald Duck ]
Uh...
♪♪
Thank you, Prince Harry
and Meghan Markle's eviction
from the royal residence,
for leading to the most epic
U-Haul procession ever.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Get it out of here!
-[ Imitates trumpets playing ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
Mandalorian helmet,
for looking like Iron Man
with Ozempic face.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Ozempic face.
-Vitamin O.
-[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Thank you, Subway building new
restaurants with playgrounds,
for being perfect for anyone
who's walked into a Subway
and thought, "If only
my kids could play here."
[ Laughter, applause ]
-I guess not.
-♪ I can dream ♪
♪ I can dream ♪
♪ I... ♪
The National's here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you,
Japan finding 7,000 islands
it didn't know existed,
for being the global version of
finding $20 in your coat pocket
and you're like...
-Hey!
-Awesome!
[ Applause ]
-Nice!
-Do the conga!
-Do the conga on this.
♪♪
-Thank you,
powdered donut holes,
for looking like something
Cocaine Bear
left behind on the trail.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa. Whoa!
Hello.
-That's exactly it.
-That's it.
-That's Cocaine Bear scat.
[ Chuckles ] Scat.
-[ Indistinct ]
♪♪
-Thank you, pistachios,
for being nut clams.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-That sounds filthy.
This is a family show!
-Nut clams.
-Nut clams?!
-[ Laughs ]
-Wait a second.
I thought you were being clean.
-We got one more joke.
-One more? Oh, my God.
-You think I can't top that one?
-You got to top nut clam.
-Oh, no way, man.
-Clam it up, G.
-Here we go.
Here we go, G.
♪♪
-Thank you, KFC,
for bringing back your
Double Down sandwich...
right in time for the finale
of "The Last of Us."
There you go, everybody.
Thank you!
Those are our thank you notes.